a government watchdog says a Peace Corps
is failing to do enough to protect
volunteers from sexual assault the
percentage of women in the Peace Corps
who say they've suffered a sexual
assault rose to 38% in 2016 that finding
came in an anonymous internal survey in
2015 a whistleblower spoke to CBS this
morning about her belief there was a
culture of victim blaming inside the
Peace Corps
she said it prevented some sexual
assault survivors from getting help her
complaint launched a lengthy
investigation the results only recently
became public currently about 7,300
Peace Corps volunteers serve in 65
countries Kris Van Cleave is outside
Peace Corps headquarters in Washington
DC and joins us Chris good morning good
morning that Peace Corps Inspector
General report found cases where the
agency failed to provide a compassionate
and supportive response to survivors of
sexual assault and that's despite the
fact that were congressionally mandated
reforms in place that were supposed to
prevent a situation like this from
happening on my first day of teaching
that was when my sexual assault occurred
on your first day my first day it was
March 2016 Peace Corps volunteer Meaghan
wreaths Miller was teaching in Uganda
she says that night the school priest
came to her door with a gift yes if we
could say a prayer together as I was
finishing out the hour father that's
when he started touching me and I
completely froze I think I sat on that
floor for probably just a half hour not
knowing what to do
not know what to say in a letter this
month the Office of Special Counsel or
OSC advised President Donald Trump the
Peace Corps is not doing enough to
protect its volunteers from sexual
assault and called for specific reforms
I feel like Peace Corps failed me every
step of the way
volunteer Denis Smith was attacked while
working in a remote Dominican Republic
village she reported it to the Peace
Corps in 2015 they told me that as a
volunteer it was my job to have been
more proactive to prevent it from
happening within a week the Peace Corps
sent her home to date we've heard from
more than two dozen former volunteers
whose stories point to a troubling
pattern one the OSC wants to check
it's calling for better training for
in-country Peace Corps host family
members and co-workers who account for
16 percent of reported sexual assaults
against volunteers there were no
appropriate boundary you see a person
who attacked me was a fellow teacher
there was no training for him there was
was no training for any of my fellow
teacher is that that school the Peace
Corps says that kind of training is not
required by law the OSC wants stricter
employee screening rules noting often
volunteers accused of sexual assault are
able to resign avoiding punishment and
any mention of the allegations in their
personnel files
one such volunteer was even rehired by
the Peace Corps in citing a recent Peace
Corps Inspector General report OSC
highlighted problems with the agency's
response to a sexual assault 14% of
assaulted volunteers had to wait more
than four weeks to get counseling and
some were limited in the number of
sessions due to a misunderstanding of
Peace Corps policy Reeth Miller was
allowed only six sessions I was
spiraling downwards and I knew it and I
asked for more counselling I called the
doctor and she said but we need to have
a serious talk about whether you're fit
to be a volunteer or not did you feel
like they were blaming you for what was
happening to you 100% do you think the
environment of the Peace Corps has
improved in the two-and-a-half years
sadly no whistleblower Kelly green was
hired as the first Peace Corps victims
advocate after Congress mandated reforms
to how the agency responded to sexual
assault cases in 2011 she says she was
pushed out for trying to change the
culture her 2015 whistleblower complaint
prompted the letter from the Special
Counsel to continually hear on a
recurring basis the same stories that
follow the same theme shows that there's
a real systemic problem within Peace
Corps the Peace Corps tells CBS this
morning it has made significant progress
in recent years having instituted more
than 30 new policies aimed at reducing
the risk of sexual assault to volunteers
and doing a better job at responding to
victims members of Congress shouldn't
have to get involved on this issue
congressman ted poe who authored the
2011 Peace Corps reforms began working
on a new bill requiring the Peace Corps
to do more to protect sexual assault
victims after our initial report that
bill is now before Congress the Peace
Corps
should have been doing the right thing
all along and coming down on the side of
our Peace Corps volunteers our Angels
abroad megan wreaths miller says she's
made progress since her assault and
would even consider going back to the
Peace Corps even though you left feeling
like they were blaming you as a victim
of sexual assault you would go back and
do it again if they changed their
policies and procedures I would the
Megan says she did report the assault to
Ugandan police but no action was taken
against the priests part of Congressman
posed legislation aims to hold foreign
nationals more responsible for crimes
against Peace Corps volunteers committed
abroad it does have bipartisan support
in the congressman says he is optimistic
it can become law this year the Peace
Corps says it is in the process of
responding to the OSC letter north great
reporting there Chris thank you so much